hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in the course of his discussion of the
second main part of Justice that is
benevolence or beneficence in his work
on duties Cicero is going to talk about
degrees of relationship degrees of
closeness to us and and what is really
required of us in terms of doing good to
other people going beyond the strict
requirements of justice itself and
showing benevolence or generosity or
moral goodness to them maybe even
showing charity he tells us that the
interests of society and it's it's
common bonds will be best conservative
kindness is shown to each individual in
proportion of the closeness of his
relationship so he says well who are we
actually connected with I notice that
the Stoics which is what he's
summarizing here they think that we do
have some sort of relationship with the
entire human race the entire species
regardless of where people are from
regardless of what language they speak
what religion they may practice what
color their skin may be all of these you
know you might say fall under the same
basic rubric of humanity and this is
what we call stoic cosmopolitanism or at
least one aspect of it the notion that
we are all related to each other in some
way that has some world obligations laid
upon us because of that so he tells us
we must trace back to their ultimate
sources of the principles of fellowship
that is communitas and society so kiya
toss that Nature has established among
human beings and he says the first
principle is that which is found in the
connection that subsists the vinculum
the the chain the bond that exists
between all the members of the human
race what is that what do we all have in
common
you might say our DNA Cicero says it's
the possession of reason and the
possession of speech which in greek by
the way are the same thing logos in
latin he talks about here we go
the bond of connection is reason Arad CO
and speech Horacio
he's playing on on the rhyme there
between the two of them and he says that
by these we are able to do teaching and
learning
communicating discussing reasoning these
associate human beings together even if
we don't speak the same language were
able to share in a common humanity and
so he goes on and he says that you know
other particular we further removed from
the nature of beasts this is what makes
us capable of justice to those with whom
we don't share a common basis because we
do have an even more common basis our
bond in our common humanity so he says
this is the most comprehensive bond that
unites human beings together and all to
all and under it he says there's a
common right to all things that nature
is produced for the common use of human
beings so although there can be private
property and there can be laws there are
certain basic things certain basic goods
you might say of the universe that we
shouldn't deprive each other of we might
think of some of these as access to fire
in ancient times or possession of clean
water an air that we can successfully
breathe in without getting cancer these
environmental things are important and
and Cicero goes further he says that
when we have human beings in a common
situation of want or danger they will
come together where they ought to come
together
instead of preying upon each other
because of their differences they ought
to come together and be good to one
another take care of each other show
benevolence or beneficence towards each
other he says in this you know that the
the poet's teach us to bestow even on a
stranger what it costs nothing to give
like like access to water he says we
should adopt these principles and always
be contributing something to the common
weal but of course you know this
visitors there's a degree to which we
can do this we can't do this with
everybody equally we have to sort of
parse it out more close is the group of
people that we feel ourselves to have
something in common with maybe to the
extent that we actually close out the
rest of the world in doing so the more
ethnocentric we are the more we're
inclined to do this so we could talk
about one's country or one's own culture
or society and he says there are many
degrees of closeness or remoteness in
human society to proceed beyond the
universal bond of our common humanity
there is the closer one of belonging to
the same people or the same tribe you
know again the the gens the not Co the
belonging to the same linguistic group
he also talks about and he says by this
people are more closely bound together
they they feel themselves to have a
greater connection they see the other as
more similar to them and they can relate
to them easier then we have in his view
one city one's local community we might
say this could be a village this could
be a metropolitan area like for instance
I'm here in Milwaukee I identify as a
person from Wisconsin in addition to
identifying as an American and in
addition to identifying as a person in
the world identify as somebody from
Wisconsin and from my City of Milwaukee
the Greater Milwaukee area in our own
time we might also think about virtual
communities
as being part of this as well these are
communities that we engage in where most
of the people that were involved with
are at best fellow citizens or neighbors
fellow residents they're not necessarily
our friends and they're not actually
related to us except in a very distant
way if at all then he says well before
we go on he says the people living in
the same community have many things in
common he says they have a common forum
that is a legal place to gather common
temples ways of worshipping the divine
common colonies interesting now we're
getting to things where the city or
private citizens have established them
and we feel that they're ours right they
feel like they belong to us like a a
sports stadium might be this way or a
common television or radio station any
of these sorts of things
streets statutes laws courts rights of
suffrage to say nothing of social and
friendly circles and diverse business
relations with many this is a much
closer set of relations than at the
level of the country then he says going
a little bit even further in a still
closer social reunions exists between
kindred starting with the infinite bond
of union of the human race in general
now we're getting to a very narrow
circle he says and he's visualizing this
as circles so he says the reproductive
instinct is by nature's gift the common
possession of all living creatures so
one of the very close connections is
that between man and woman in the family
or in a marriage reproduction right so
he says husband and wife the next
between parents and children then we
find one home with everything in common
and this may include many generations
and he says this is the foundation of
civil government then follow the bonds
between brothers and sisters between
siblings then those are first and second
cousins and then when they can't be
sheltered
the same roof we have clan structures
you might say or or you know larger
assemblages of people who say oh you're
my cousin's you're related to me we're
part of this group that's a much closer
circle now here's the the fundamental
question that comes up
now that we've distinguished all of
these interesting concentric circles of
closeness you know or proximity and that
distance going all the way out to the
entire human race who do we owe the
greatest affection or who should we be
benevolent to some people might say well
you should think about the entire human
race you shouldn't play favorites
wherever your your money or your time
can do the most good this is the notion
of effective altruism that's where you
should be putting it Cicero doesn't
think that's the case Cicero says that
and this is his view on this and he's
not necessarily along with the Stoics
and all of this country should come
first he says here here we go he says
that when with a rational spirit you
surveyed the whole field there's no
social relation among them more clothes
none more deer than latley which links
each of us with our country parents our
dear children our dear relatives friends
but one native land embraces all of our
loves and who that is true would
hesitate to give his life for her if by
his death he could render her a service
he also says those who do damage to
their country to their their community
this might be you know betraying the
country this might actually be
destroying the economy this might be
environmental damage he says they're
traitors they are exa [ __ ] you know
they're they're terrible people they're
monsters here he's actually talking
about Caesar and other people of his ilk
so he says if a contrast
Harrison were to be made to find out
where most our moral obligations do
country would come first that would come
family and within the family parents
first then children then the whole
family who looked he says to us for
support and you'd have no other
protection then our kinsmen like second
cousins people like that and then you
know the rest of the world or then one
city so there is a clear priority a very
interesting difference though he talks
about friends friends are different than
family although there's nothing to keep
you from being friends with your brother
or your father or your child or or
anything like that but he does say that
that friends he says the bonds of
friendship there is none more noble none
more powerful than when good men of
congenial character are joined an
intimate friend net friendship for if we
discover it another that moral goodness
we it attracts us and makes us friends
to those two the one in whose character
it seems to dwell and virtue attracts us
justice and generosity in particular he
says now what do we owe our friends we
don't know them the same thing as we owe
our country we don't owe them the same
thing as we owe our family friendship
and familial relations are not exactly
the same thing it's a different kind of
affection for the ancients so he tells
us that intimate relationship of life
and living counsel conversation and
here's a really interesting
encouragement comfort and sometimes even
reproof sometimes even criticism
sometimes saying what the hell is wrong
with you buddy that belongs to
friendship that is what we owe to them
we don't necessarily owe that to our
countrymen we should have something like
that within certain parts of our family
but Cicero thought that we will also
need friends for this as well he talks
about the the the need for Congeniality
or kin
action of character having people who
are who are like us and that may not be
the case with with the country but with
each of these there's a certain type of
beneficence or benevolence that's do
certain modality we owe something to
members of the human race as members of
the human race we owe something to those
who are in our close circle of family
and friends we owe things to those with
whom we share in a community but we have
to look at these things
according to Cicero rationally we don't
want to just try to give everybody the
same thing that would not actually be
beneficence and that would not lead to
justice so this is how Cicero conceives
of it with these concentric circles and
these duties that are owed to people who
are closer to us
you